so when we heard that seth rogen was
going to be the Green Hornet we all
thought the same thing a hero that guy
the Green Hornet so the Green Hornet's
the story of a rich guy played by Seth
Rogen who also wrote the movie who's
just been wasting his life until his dad
dies and he and his friend Kato help a
couple from being mugged then after that
the like we should do that more often we
should be heroes which really works out
because Kato is a badass at everything
he does mean martial arts making weapons
brew and coffee the guys he's just
skilled and now we have our superhero
movie or hero movie or antihero movie
kinda so I'm going to be completely
honest with you guys when I saw the
trailers for this movie I was not
impressed and I went on Rotten Tomatoes
today and it currently has like a 42% so
I was just like alright I'm gonna watch
a superhero movie I'm gonna rip
into it for the good people of YouTube
it's gonna be a good time but I actually
really enjoyed this movie which really
shows two things one Rotten Tomatoes
doesn't mean and two pretty much
the same as one I mean come on it's a
cool movie with a couple of cool
characters witty dialogue and a badass
villain played by the Jew hunter
Kristoff vaults I mean come on can you
really ask for more especially in a
January movie I mean it's a hilarious
movie it's a hilarious hero movie
because that is what it is and if you're
one of those people who are like it's
not a tour de force with a bravura
performance or one of the other hundred
terms that we use to make ourselves
sound smarter like good elitist what is
the world coming to or this is just
nothing like the old TV show they're
just butchering the lore first of all
get this out of your ass that is a
big-ass steak and second and I'm gonna
put this as delicately as I possibly can
it's the Green Hornet no one has given a
about it since 1968 yes when your
basic living room still look like that
that is when people stop giving a
about the Green Hornet Seth Rogen and
company have taken a dead franchise
giving it CPR and wrote a fun movie with
really witty dialogue they made it
modern and quite frankly if it was like
I must find the culprits Kato they must
be stopped they must be brought to
justice by the Green Hornet how boring
would that have been I say go check it
out it's a good time no alcohol acquired
and I'll probably even get it even on
blu-ray
and I will say this about the 3d it is
converted 3d but it's the most
impressive converted 3d that I've
personally seen but still Satan 2d
support the movie don't support the
converted 3d and if you like what
you've seen here and you want to see
more than click right here to see more